[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically in your money in your work
and in your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw my friend and
colleague joins me this hour we're here
to answer your questions she'll be
taking your questions I'll chime in I'll
be taking any questions about personal
growth in your work and do you want to
get ahead and how to get ahead and
managing this money Journey alongside of
that and Jade will wait in on that as
well the phone number for you to jump in
is 88255
225 8825 5225 I also say this I'll say a
little bit more as we get closer to it
but a special treat today and the clue
is the word treat oo that's all I can
say right now well I can say more I just
don't want to don't give it away Kim I'm
not going to give it away give it away
give it away now I was thinking that
were you thinking that I was like
Anthony ke has told us to give it away
but don't give it away love that uh
let's get to the phones Levi is up first
in Tampa Florida Levi how can we
help
Levi okay uhoh I hit the button I
promise I hit line one so we're not
getting Levi this happens from time to
time that's all right we can keep it
roll I think James James is going to
help us out
you Levi Levi what's going
on okay hi everyone uh so my name is
Levi I am in
$200,000 of student loan debt I am I am
I am an attorney I make 115k a year uh
take-home income is about 6,200 I also
uh DJ and create content on the side uh
My overall take-home income per month is
about 6,800 okay here's my question
here's my question um I want to
refinance my student loans to get a
lower interest payment right now my
interest is %. if I refinance right now
my interest payment will or my interest
rate will be and somewhere between seven
and 7.5% that's great should I ref
Should I refinance like right now or
should I wait for interest rates to
lower how long have you been out of
school so um I GR graduated from Law
School in 2020 uh which was during Co I
didn't and my student loan I never had
to pay any student loan any student
loans and now they've just kicked back
in and I've made a couple payments um
I listen and and they're all
private they're all uh Federal oh so
you're consolidating them at 7.5% you're
not necessarily re refinancing
them uh see and answers like that is
that's exactly why I called it in the
ranty show I don't really know no it's
okay with with with Federal loans you
can consolidate them down and they'll
group them all together and they'll put
them at one one interest rate which is
not always for some people it's not
always the best move but it sounds like
in your case it is the best move the
thing that you need to realize with that
is you get one shot to do it and so I
think that's why you're kind of worried
of should I do it now or should I
wait that's accurate okay um with your
well let me ask you a couple more
questions before we get to that do you
have any other
debt um well I've listening to the
Ramsey Show for about three months and
over the last three months I paid off
all my credit card debt sweet awesome
anything else
cars um my car is 100% paid off as of
about six months ago um I right now I
pay and you're probably not gonna like
this I pay 12250 in rent but I'm ready
for an upgrade sorry and and who are you
apologizing to not me
well well I mean you know right now the
the the Deb snowball is 200k and if I ra
if I raise my rent it's going to be you
know $2,000 is but I'm sorry I don't
have an inunit washer dryer like I'm
ready for an upgrade here okay that's
your choice if you choose to do that I
mean if you go to 2,000 you're still not
um I mean you're you're going over 25%
if you do
that of your take-home
pay right okay is that like is 25% like
the metric that I should wear when we
when we talk about buying a house it
definitely is and in your case with baby
step 2 I would highly I would still
consider that kind of a a framework I
like where you're at now and I want you
to move up in hotel in in hotel my
goodness I want you to move up in
apartment is there any any way that you
can save it until after you pay off this
debt because here's the thing that extra
$800 or $750
that we're talking about months of
Freedom there and you've got to really
weigh the opportunity cost of if whether
you take that extra $750 and get your
end unit because it feels like that's
kind of a celebratory thing for you or
kind of like a status thing like listen
I deserve this I've been working hard
I've been in law school Give me the give
me the apartment I want and I understand
that but man oh man having that extra
750 over the course of time knocking out
these student loans that is a big big
big deal and I do want you to weigh that
heavily have you done the math out on
that yeah you're you're absolutely right
I I have done the math out on that and
it's not pretty but what about a
roommate um not willing yeah if he's
ready to do that he doesn't want to live
with anybody you got to make a decision
and I just think this is a bad idea I
think it's a bad idea for you to
increase your expenses right now when
it's really not that big of a lifestyle
issue I get why you feel the way you
feel but now we're always get going to
give you the advice that says sacrifice
sacrifice sacrifice cuz we want you to
get free sooner as Jade said so we're
not going to be in favor of that how
many uh how much of so you're bringing
home 6,800 how much of that is going
towards your um debt at this
point so right now I put about $2,000
per month to student loans okay so
that's well above and and I I picked
like an income driven repayment plan
this is before I became with the Dave
Ramsey Show on YouTube and now it's like
my my payments are 600 something dollars
which is laughable so I've been
overpaying my payments what kind of law
do you
practice workers comp what's your uh
what's the ladder look like over the
next one to three
years financially for you when you say
lad like how much more can I make over
the next one to three years yeah with a
lot of I want to know how you can
increase this income because that's what
needs to happen we need to be busting it
uh well it staying at the stay staying
where I currently am which I'm planning
on doing I could probably go up to
probably 130 140 over the next uh three
years okay no freelance
opportunities um not really uh The Firm
that I'm at I would need to disclose and
get approval for a lot you understand
why I'm asking that right I mean
$200,000 very doable with with your
ability but you're going to have to
increase your income this it's going to
be a long journey yes and no yes you do
need to in increase your income but I I
kind of think 2,000 are you single yes
I'm I think 2,000 if you're making 6,800
a month you have no other payments
besides this I think 2,000 a month is a
little
wimpy okay how what what would not be
wimpy I think I think that there's areas
in your budget that you can cut more and
I sense that because I'm looking at the
numbers and I also sense that because
you're creeping up on wanting another
apartment already and so I just sense
that there's things in your life that
you're like listen I've earned this I
want to spend my money on this and
that's true but again you're weighing
that opportunity cause I think you can
squeak another $500 or th000 out of this
budget I think you need to do what K did
and you need to get your income up I
don't want this taking you eight years
to pay off that's far too long I want
this done in four years and you can do
that yeah good stuff thanks for the call
glad you've joined our community stay
with us you will get through this all
right we're just getting started folks
Merry Christmas to one and and all don't
move more of your calls coming up this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a five $5,000 seller guarantee
gives your offer the best chance of
being accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show thrilled
to have you with us I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw joins me and we are here for you
America triple 8825 5225 is the phone
number 8825 5225 taking your questions
about money and I'm in the chair today
so let's take any questions about
personal and professional growth
decisions about maybe starting a
business uh when do I go from side
hustle to fulltime uh hey I'm stuck I
need a promotion I'm not getting it any
kind of work rated questions because
those are always money related and uh
we'd love to take some of those as well
so jump in8 825 5225 and uh if you want
to stay with us if it's kind of like
well we're getting this is like the like
uh what second to the last Friday of the
of the Year am I right did I get that
right and you're kind of just like I
think I'll hang out today you don't want
to miss next hour Jade got another
special treat I get to sample it there's
another clue uh you're really hype in
this up Ken well you know I even broke
out the cardigan today uh the new
cardigan sweater you look like a a
stickle of bourbon a
stickle that feels right I don't know
what that is but that doesn't offend me
at all it feels right let's get to
Stephen in Houston Texas Stephen how can
we
help oh hi hi guys thanks for taking the
call you bet what's going on so I'm
looking for some advice uh uh we just me
and my wife just recently uh got on the
ramay plan where on baby step 2 and I'm
a full-time High School
teacher um and I've taken I've taken a
part-time EMS job when I'm out on on
vacation and uh on the weekends and
stuff and I do some food delivery uh to
try to just pack as much money as we can
to this debt wow but I'm AF I'm
afraid that um my wife is getting
overwhelmed by it
so because you're not home what's going
on man you're pretty emotional right now
what are you
feeling I just I you know it's like a
baby Christian you know I don't want to
I don't want to be so intense that she's
like oh you know you won't let us do
anything and and this and that what's
going on I don't know how to have that
how that conversation well take us to
what's going on with you guys
relationally what what are you feeling
from her what are you hearing from her
that you would call us about
this well um it like like uh for
instance she works full-time at home we
have two kids okay and um so when I'm
like all right I'm gonna go I have a
goal to make $50 a day with food
delivery okay um five days a week so
that's extra $1,000 a month and then on
uh Saturdays I go work this EMS job
which are 24-hour chefs oh man and
that's extra $360 each day I do that and
then but she still like well you think
you can stay home tonight so that uh you
know we can clean the house and get
ready for our Christmas brunch that's
coming up and and um I don't I
I I I I I'm like well you think that
maybe you you know you could pick up a
little bit of that so that we can
continue to stay on plan okay I see
what's going on here yeah and then I get
kind of negative feedback well you know
well so now we just you're not here to
help around in the house and stuff like
that I let me ask a couple clarifying
questions when you said she works
full-time does she work full-time as a
stay-at-home mom or does she work
full-time at a job that is work from
home yeah a job that work from home okay
but there the kids are also there too so
that kind of falls on her as well right
when when they're not in school like
right now we're on Christmas break I
totally get that okay and then can you
tell me how much debt do you guys have
cuz I'm trying to understand I mean I
the intensity but I want to I just want
to get a bigger picture Okay so uh we
have about uh uh
$226,000 in uh cars and uh credit cards
break it down which what's the cars and
what's the credit cards uh my wife's car
is almost paid off it's got 3,000 left
my truck's got 11,000 left and then we
have uh about 155,000 in credit cards
okay and then um another 10,000 around
on that that I owed to my uh to my
mother-in-law my St what's the payoff
date if you didn't miss any night
scheduled you've got this thing figured
out if you stay on this pace what do you
anticipate the day would be how far in
the future before you pay off this debt
I I I I I told my wife we can do it in
six months not our house I I have a
house sure sure sure sure so let me just
tell you hey so Stephen so manto man
here uh I love this intensity but U
there this is a six month window it'd be
different if this were a six year and
you guys had to be that intense I love
the intensity I think you have to
downshift in moments like this when your
wife is giving you the signal you read
it man you've been married long enough
you know uh going after it but but if
there's a holiday party in the situation
you gave us I think the answer and this
is not criticism you called so I'm going
to tell you as a dude just my take here
in that situation uh you take the night
off from gazelle intensity and you jump
in and help her out I I think if you
guys were in much bigger debt and it
were far more intense I think there's a
conversation to be had to say hey babe I
got to do this we got to be all in but I
think given this situation I don't think
this is three or four nights a week I
think you sit down with her and go hey
I'm doing this to Sprint hang in there
but if you need you need that kind of
emergency situation raise your hand and
I'm going to be more sensitive next time
and I'll jump in that would be my take
in this situ
what's you guys's combined income yearly
you mentioned all the things you're
doing but what does that amount
to uh so that's recent the uh the EMS
job and stuff but so right now we make
about 110 gross together just got of
regular jobs and I'm looking to bring in
uh I I got plan to bring in 3,000 extra
a month so uh about 30,000 more so maybe
about 140,000 if I stay on this track
okay so you're basic basically saying
our normal budget stays the same and I'm
side hustling to pay off I get it that
caused a little tral too because then we
strip the budget way down as well we cut
off some streaming services well that's
what I'm saying it it almost needs to be
one or the other because you've got
$39,000 of debt and you just outlined a
plan where you're side hustling to bring
in an extra almost
40,000 so if the side hustling alone is
paying off the debt then like I'm trying
to find a way where you guys can balance
this out a little bit a little bit more
does does that make sense because if you
okay yeah I understand if if you're
going to bring in $40,000 a year and
this is a a full year play as opposed to
you just trying to like to Ken's point
just squeak this thing out in six months
I do think that you
know if you can get her on board fine
but like Ken said you know if she's
having these moments where she's
throwing a flag on the play like listen
we haven't seen you we don't we don't
even remember what you look like dude
like you do have to you have to cool out
for a minute right and I think that um I
think there's room for you to take the
pedal off the metal just a little bit
yeah right great because I don't want to
burn her out so I so I guess that's I
looking for to say your instincts are
right yeah she's like a baby bird
sometimes you got to get them to keep
yeah keep coming to you Stephen I think
your instincts are right you called us
we're validating your instincts your
instincts are right you're pushing
really hard and it's affecting her and
you don't want to lose her and in in the
midst of this cause
the cause is not as important as as her
and the kids because it's not at that
point what's the point especially during
this that's right but listen my man she
seems to be Allin we heard no signs of
her not being Allin it's just hey we got
a holiday party and I'm swamped with the
kids and I'm exhausted you know I also
think it's important for you to uh show
some appreciation to her for her being
all in and you know what maybe take a
night uh coming up in the next couple
weeks and totally surp surpris her and
say hey babe here's a little money that
I've been making on the side hustle go
out with some of your best girlfriends
have a nice night I'll take care of the
kids all right Ken colan do you know I
mean what do you think Jade I think
that's a teamwork play that's a teamwork
play cuz she's listen I'm just I'm
honoring all the moms out there cuz my
wife has has has done both Stacy has
fluctuated between being a work out of
the home and a work in the home notice I
say work in the home cuz that's a lot of
work and there are times where it's
really good guys for us to just
acknowledge uh the partner in the
situation and uh and say hey you know
what I appreciate you being on board and
what it when you're going at that pace
you have to ahead of time say what the
Milestones are going to be when we pay
off this car we get this when we do this
and it sounds like they don't have those
milestones in place and that is so
important you need like a cheat day you
know these big time athletes like I I
follow the rock no big deal you know I
like the rock cheat meals have you seen
the man's cheat meals it's pretty
fantastic
so even one of the greatest athletes
actors you know get after guys in the
world you got those down days I think
mama needs a little little little time
off every once in a while and you can
fund that and then we keep going with
great momentum Stephen you're a good man
and a good husband this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show hey guys I've told you before about
ch Healthcare Ministries a health cost
sharing Ministry but listen to Jenna a
chm member she says one of my biggest
concerns about entrepreneurship and
motherhood was figuring out how to take
care of our health expenses but we have
found a solution that works for us in an
incredible way she loves that with chm
she can help other families who need it
and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me in studio
we're here for you America 88255 2225
88255 225 taking your money questions
your work questions it's a good time to
be thinking about next year and we are
here for you the question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your help
for Home Services neighbor has local
service providers who can repair
maintain and improve your home ladies if
you're married to a guy like me you need
neighborly cuz I can't do jack Diddley
squat around the house and that's why
Stacy is happy for neighborly their
network of experts offer top quality
work and customer service by trained
reliable service providers find the help
you need at neighborly
docomo today's question comes from Sarah
in Arizona can I donate money in baby
step 2 my husband and I disagree about
this I made my husband do I made my
husband do FPU and agreed to the
principles before I would even accept
his proposal wow dang son we just got
married in September and we are
officially on a budget with combined
finances we have a good income around
400,000 combined but our debt snowball
is more of a debt wrecking ball right
now
448,000 in total debt I have always
given $100 a month to Charities and I
put these as line items on our combined
budget my husband says giving is for
baby step seven and this money should
come out of my discretionary spending if
I want to keep giving I say it is I say
it is not $100 a month that is going to
derail us from reaching our goals I'm
still tweaking the budget but right now
I have our individual allowance at $200
each month can you please be the
arbitrator of this debate oh I need to
get you I need to get you one of those
black robes and you're judge Jade right
now need to give you a gavel too what
say you judge Jade I I see a lot in this
so I'm just going to pick it apart um
this woman is strong you think okay I do
not want to mess with Sarah Sarah is
coming in hot okay um here's what I'm
going to say about giving and then I'm
going to go back through uh this thing I
do think it's important to give I think
giving is an important practice that you
you do all the time all the time even in
baby step two now pause for a second I'm
going to tell you my perspective and you
have the ability Sarah to put this make
it make it make sense for you depending
on your belief system I'm a Christian
person the way I believe is you just
give 10% off the top all the time and
you give that 10% to your local church
that's that's what I believe that's a
spiritual practice for me but it's also
a financial practice and generosity for
me so even while Sam and I were in baby
step two with um almost the same amount
of debt as what you have Sarah but with
a smaller income we continue to give not
$100 a month but 10% of whatever we
brought in and for me the reasoning
behind that is not just like I said a
spiritual one but it is a practice and
just good Financial principle because at
the end of the day and this is for
everybody listening when you have a open
hand the money is sitting in your hand
money can easily get out but it also
means money can easily get back in and
that's a wonderful thing to know and
it's just a blessing we say it all the
time giving is the most fun you can have
with money so um I agree with you in
principle yes you should continue to
give matter of fact up it if you're
making $400,000 a year and you want to
give 10% well there you have it
um what your husband is talking about
baby step seven he says giving is for
baby step seven that really is if you
want to give above and beyond right if
you're like listen we've been at this um
this lower Mark of giving for a while
we're ready to increase there's some
dreams that I have yeah baby step seven
is the time to do that
um I I I might
just and it might just be the way it's
written maybe just just ease up a little
Sarah just maybe maybe pull back a
little bit you're very you're very
strong and all of these things kind of
sound like I told my husband we're doing
this and I told him we're doing this and
you're kind of like dragging him by the
collar she got him like like the collar
on the wall you know what I'm saying um
yeah and I think that might make him
feel a little he might be feeling some
type of way and maybe this is is a way
where he feels like he can get a little
control back because you know sometimes
relationships get to be a bit of a power
struggle
and so this feels more about a power
struggle than it really does about
giving I'm not going to lie just reading
it I may be wrong Ken Coleman uh I think
you're right I think the language
implies her attitude towards him and uh
you don't want to take too many
liberties with just a one-sided email um
but yeah it feels like this is not a
partnership this is a dictatorship is
what it feels like and so I think you're
right the budget needs to be a apted
yeah to include include the giving that
you're talking about based on what we
teach so I agree with you a lock step uh
man I get it though you know money
creates enough tension us telling the
spouse how things are going to be that
doesn't lend itself to longterm
Financial partnership it doesn't and I
mean Sarah hear me loud and clear I I
have a Mr T personality as well okay
like I pity the fool I pity the fool
like I I come in hot like Sam warshaw he
can tell you right now I come in hot and
so when I read that I recognized that
and so like we sometimes we have to pull
back a little bit we we stomp in the
room you know what I'm saying we just
chill out and guys even if she does
stomp in the room never say that she
Stomps in the room there's a little bit
of advice to all the dudes out there we
float man I'm already getting nervous I
feel like I'm on eggshells already I'm
ready to move on by the way uh the
illustrious uh incomparable Sam warshaw
is in the lobby so he gave a look he
kind of leaned over and gave me a look
when you said that that's all he did I
don't know what that means I'll find out
afterwards oh boy that's good stuff all
right Britney's up next in New Orleans
or as I like to say nins what's going on
Britney hi K how are you guys we're
having a blast what are you up
to working is that snowball I have a
question hey before you ask the question
I got to know when you live in the New
Orleans area is it a thing does
everybody have beignet around Christmas
is that a Christmas morning
thing uh I prefer sweet potato oh okay
around this time of the year personally
I just want you to know I order every
year a box of uh of the dough from Cafe
Dumont and we do beignet Christmas
morning wow yeah that's my that's my
treat anyway sorry I got distracted
Britney what can we answer good yeah
they are good okay so I'm working on my
debt snowball and the next debt I have
coming up is a personal loan for $5,000
now I was previously married before and
so this is a loan that I hold with my
ex-husband uh when we split we did agree
to split it 50/50 and we've been paying
the monthly payment um since we split
now okay it's the next thing in my that
snowball so obviously I'm trying to
figure out what to do because he does
not have his half of the 5,000 to pay it
off currently who do you owe the money
to
um one
main okay so it's okay Lending Service
okay it's a personal loan from A bank
not like Grandma Lo loaned you money
okay corre yes um has is he good for it
like has tell me what kind of guy this
is is this the type of guy who's gonna
pay
it he's been paying it monthly he's late
sometimes but he always gives it um but
you know is it in both of your names for
the most part yes it both of our name
I'd
probably I'd probably pay my half and
set it set it aside and then by the time
I get done with my debt snowball if he
still hasn't paid it I'm G to pay it and
move on okay that's what I was thinking
should I just pay the whole thing now
here's the thing if you start to see
because I here's the thing you pay half
of this and there's still a monthly
payment due so you need to monit monitor
this and if you see listen he's not
making his payment this interest is
racking up and it's going the the bill
is is going up it's not going down you
need to you need to reach over and just
pay it off immediately but if you see
okay he's making his payment you know
this this is working cuz you know
$2,500 is a lot of money I might change
my mind hold on a second how much more
do you have in your debt
snowball uh if I sell my car which I
plan on doing I'll have about 40K left
40K left um and how much is the car
worth the car is like 20 all right if
you don't sell that car because I think
that's a big part of this pay your hat
and watch it all right watch it every
month because I don't want this going
back if you see even one month that he's
late reach over and pay it off all
right thank you for the call Britney
when you said reach I thought you said
reach over and cuffing right in the back
of the head but she could try that too
she could try that too hey Britney
you're doing awesome you're on your way
and nobody's going to stop you thanks
for the call great advice Jay all right
don't move folks we got to pay a couple
bills and we'll be right back this is
the ramsy
[Applause]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships we want you winning
in all three of those areas and that's
why we do this show the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman Jade warshaw joins me8
825-5222
55225 let's go to Toronto Canada Max
joins us there Max how can we
help hey Ken thank you guys so much for
having me on can you hear me okay yes
sir what's going
on awesome yeah so I'll kind of just
give you the question and then I guess
we can dive into it so I'm 23 graduated
University uh two years ago now and
thinking of moving on for my first
full-time job and uh taking a shot as an
entrepreneur doing some social media and
YouTube content okay and uh what do you
make in your full-time
job uh so right now I'm at 80,000 I also
have a side hustle that I'm doing about
5k a month oh wow what's the side
hustle yeah so I'm parting this company
called odds jam and it's a little bit
weird but kind of with a lot of the new
um Sports books and gambling companies
coming to Canada uh there's a lot of
opportunities for different promotions
and things like that so using the
software I've been uh able to have
success and average about 5k a month
past year wow and so where does the
YouTube social media Venture that you
mentioned does this is this uh is this
related at all to the work you just
described it's the side hustle or is it
completely separate no so it would be
completely separate kind of my game plan
would be to continue to do the side
hustle and then kind of leave this
full-time job and then be able to fully
dive into you know doing 60 80 hours a
week on the the YouTube soci do you have
any debt right now nope no debt no debt
at all you're
single uh I have a girlfriend of three
years girlfriend of three years um what
kind of content are you planning to do
social media and
YouTube yeah so it would be kind of in
the self-improvement self-development
space specifically here to a target
audience of young men probably within
the age of 14 to 22 a lot of it would
kind of be either Fitness related at
ated mental health building
self-discipline confidence um some stuff
with how to have success with women as
well as business have you done any of
that content before or is this just an
idea uh so I haven't done any of that
content before but I am publishing a 300
page uh selfimprovement book in January
so that's going to be coming in the next
month and all the things I talk about
kind of in the book are going to be
directly related to the content I'm
doing on the Channel all right well then
based on what you've told me I think
what I would do if I were you is I would
release that book proud of you for that
I think that's great I would start doing
this content now I would not go all in
to me it just is not worth taking a
$20,000 pay cut I love that you're
making 80k in a day job that that is
allowing you enough bandwidth mentally
to be making 60 you're on Pace to make
$60,000 a year in a side hustle so I
wouldn't just immediately walk away from
the
80k um and and to go all in on the
social because I don't think that's the
right strategy I think what I would do
is I would come up with a strategy to
test this what's a legitimate test and
I'm making this up please don't let me
hang this on you and I want Jade to
weigh in here in a second on this too
but but I would be thinking um social
and YouTube so is it three videos a week
is it one how many posts a day get
whatever you think is a legitimate test
not be allend all because remember
starting a social media side also should
have the same mindset as starting a
regular brick-and-mortar business
meaning I'm not going to go all in on a
bunch of inventory buy a building I'm
going to lease I'm going to do a small
inventory I'm going to test this stuff
so to me I would stay put doing exactly
what you're doing now and what I would
do is is I would commit 20 hours a week
to it uh 15 whatever you can do let's go
full-blown test because you could still
hustle right now put out enough content
to test it and see is there anything
there then what I would like to see is
social media this new side hustle uh the
personal development stuff I'd like to
see that getting to a point where you
can see it generating 20,000 so that we
replace the 80k from the day job there's
just zero reason for you to risk right
now also that book when did you say the
book comes
out uh so the launch is plann for the
end of January of this year okay 2024 I
guess I I'm I'm just asking is this is
this something you've done on your own
like you found a publisher and you did
this or is there some sort of deal that
you got because of something you did and
there's a little bit more hoopla around
it can you tell us like the the the
seriousness of this
yeah yeah so I wrote the entire book
myself and then I worked with another
publishing company in Canada which kind
of helped me with you know cover design
going through the manuscript you know
going over everything with a fine tooth
a fine tooth
comb but it's up to you to Market it
yeah exactly okay so I think to Ken's
point that book is going to be a big
test for you too because you're going to
look and see okay like is it selling are
people interested in this topic what's
the feedback you know on on Amazon
you'll be able to read those reviews and
see everything that's going on um with
that book so that's one of the ways
you'll test it but I you know Ken and I
can both tell you from social media
before I came to Ramsey I started a a
channel and it is hard work people you
know people like to look at influen and
go oh you're you're an influencer how
hard could it be and I'm like no no no
no no no no it's hard work it's very
hard to get people um I mean you're it's
a constant competition to make sure your
content is what people want to see so do
you plan on having somebody to help you
with it or are you going is the first
step just you doing it on your
own yeah so kind of my my thought
process with and I know that this is
someone you guys have on the show Alex
mosy and kind of something that he says
is a lot of people that kind of have one
foot in the door one foot out the door
and that's kind of why I wanted to quit
and go full-time in it because I feel
you know something Ken talks about as
well as I don't necessarily have to
Career capital in terms of editing video
skills and stuff I feel the skill I do
have is great communication and you know
I I believe myself that if I commit to
this for you know a threeyear time
window let's say and I'm doing 68 hours
a week on it I believe I can do for
festival it's more so just having that
time that I don't really have you know
working 9 to5 and you know regarding
what Ken said earlier you know 20 hours
a week something like that know I do
think that I can do that but a big part
of it is also Fitness right so I'm in
the gym probably 2 3 hours a day so on
top of my 9 to-5 and the side hustle I
don't really have a lot of free time in
the day per se so that's why I'm at a
bit of a Crossroads if that makes sense
well let me address because I've
interviewed Alex uh and know Alex and so
I want to address what you said I think
it's it's correct what he has said but
there's also scaling involved and
there's a season when we're testing and
then there's a season when we scale
scale and I this is what I heard you say
is just quit everything and go 80 hours
a week to be able to do this did I hear
that
correctly I would still do the side
hustle that I'm doing the odds the end
that put that put you so how many hours
a week do you have to put into that
that's making you 5K a month probably
two hours a day every day okay well
listen I'm not going to tell you not to
do it I told you what I would do and I
would eventually ramp up I'm with Alex
that at some point you've got to go all
in I just don't think you're ready to go
all in yet yeah how quickly okay let's
say you're replacing the 5,000 a month
that you're making from your $80,000 job
that you're um netting how quickly do
you think by posting on social media and
YouTube that you'll recoup that in your
mind how quickly do you think yeah I
think if I regular years how long if I
do two years two years that' probably be
800 videos I think I could have a good
Audience by
then it's it's it's very speculative
it's very spec I'm just saying it's very
speculative cuz I again this is this is
from somebody who's saying who's doing
what you're saying to do I did it for
two and a half years and I had just
started making money just in when I say
money I mean a little bit of money not
not anything close to bank just a little
bit of money having some opportunities
to like influence for people she's
really good she's really Winsome I'm
just going to be honest with you I mean
she's people like looking at her and
listening to what she says she's Dynamic
and it took her that long she's a big-
Time performer I would just rather you
take my advice now because I think I'm
right and you'll get there because I
think it's I think it's not going to
hurt you you got to try this I I know
you don't have a lot of time to be able
to crank out but start working that gym
time into video time if you're in the
gym for two hours then figure out a way
to film it film the whole time you got
some extra money I'd hire somebody to be
following you around you know that's
what Alex does Alex has got a guy that's
full-time following around shooting
stuff and editing I'd rather you keep
the day job invest some of that money in
somebody filming you while you're at the
gym for 2 hours but test it and then
when we know it's really working then we
scale it J um I just don't want you to
go backwards financially Max but I love
your heart and uh your desire so thanks
for the call Jade warshaw good hour
thank you my friend to our fearless
leader old Captain our Captain James
Childs and The Fearless crew in the
thank you guys this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the ramsy show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money in your
work and through your relationships
triple 8825
5225 that's the number to jump in Jade
warshaw joins me I'm Ken Coleman and we
are thrilled to be with you to answer
your questions we're for you let us
coach you up today 8825 5225 Jade
specializing in the money questions I'll
specialize in any work related questions
we'll co uh we'll kind of tag team any
question that comes in and uh we believe
that your best days are ahead Triple 8
225 special segment coming up later this
hour uh Jade I I I want you to to tease
it uh however you choose to tease it cuz
these are my favorite segments of all
segments and I don't care if Dave's
listening George Rachel John I don't
care this is why I love hosting
co-hosting the ramsy show has that a
setup okay Ken you didn't have to fire
shots but why that's fantastic this is
great yeah we're talking about it's the
holidays right Christmas is coming up
this weekend and then you got New Year's
and hosting parties Ken there's always
these expectations how can we save money
and have a great contribution in the
midst of that so we are going to have a
a test a taste off of I'm going to be uh
subjecting myself to your tips that's
right and then I am just supposed to
comment and this is my favorite thing to
do that's right uh there will be
beverages can you tell the difference
between a a $10 bottle of wine and a $30
bottle away we're about to find out uh
in this sweater today you would think I
would know but I I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know if it's
all surface or if I have a pallet that
is uh that is good enough so we'll see
so that's the that's you don't want to
miss it uh and you're actually going to
learn something and save money thanks to
my bright colleague over here so it's
going to be a lot of fun I can't wait
I'm already getting hungry and thirsty
let's go to Rebecca in Portland Maine
Rebecca how can we
help hi good afternoon everybody how you
doing good afternoon Rebecca how can we
help hi so um I'm trying to figure out
how I can get started on paying down uh
some all of my debt um and what I had
told um the dispatchers when I called in
was that so we are on a Section 8
voucher and so it goes by income and so
between that and then my son's SSI like
our income's kind of limited and so I've
got already like deup of calling me and
our rent's going up in a week and a half
after the first so I'm trying to figure
out
how I can start slowly paying down these
debts given what our new budget's going
to be okay how much debt do you have
total rough roughly about I to take
educated gu 5,000 5,000 and it's what
credit cards credit cards yes okay so 5K
and credit card debt and that's it what
about Transportation how are you what's
your situation there ended up we just
ended up actually having to junk our car
about two weeks ago so right now we
don't have a vehicle um we try to take
public transit up here um but the public
transit isn't very good it buses here
run about once every two hours oh man so
we've been having yeah we've been having
to take uh a lot of list and Ubers
around so i' say about weekly with that
I have to do two a day let's see there I
round it up about $20 or 20 expensive
I'm gonna say probably about1 120 a week
almost an Uber yeah so we need a car
okay now you outlined a little bit of
the the Section 8 and the SSI I'm not an
expert on that so I might ask you a lot
of questions um how much are you
bringing in and are there any
limitations on your income because of
the
SSI okay so with SSI uh my son's SSI is
based off of my husband's income so that
tend to fluctuate uh I know for January
he'll be getting roughly I'm just
grounded off to about 800 a month
starting in January but that could
change in the future uh what my husband
gets bi-weekly after taxes Etc is taking
out is about 1,500 after taxes um and
then um what was the last thing our rent
is going up uh after the first to just
over 1,600 and obviously with any
programs whether it's section A or any
Medicaid programs they count everything
pre-tax so this is net pay that I'm
talking about so you get
1,600 the the section you pay 1600
towards that's what it's worth
yes okay all right so I'm looking at
your income and I'm like okay I'm seeing
$2,300 is is that right the 800 from SSI
and the, 1500 from your
husband oh oh he gets bi-weekly I should
say sorry about 1,500 by weekly I'm your
husband yes okay so $3,000 a month yes
and then the the the 800 from sa SS SSI
so 3,800 is what you're working with yes
total yes okay now what happens if you
bring in more
money I have to report it to our local
housing agency and then they have to
calculate recalculate what our rent's
going to be which is part of the reason
why um I haven't worked I'm also uh
disabled and I have two disabled lot of
my three kids are um on the autis in
Spectrum so they're considered disabled
so but yes so it does affect our housing
and anything else we get like right now
we don't get snapped because we're over
income for
okay let me I'm I'm going to just throw
out a bunch of stuff and you poke holes
in it but I'm going to throw it out here
and Ken you're the career guy what I
know is there's a lot of work from home
positions a lot a lot a lot and you're
talking to me on the phone and I know
exactly what's going on you're here with
me so my question is is there anything
that you can do from home you're working
on your computer you're working on the
phone lines I don't want you
stuck in this and I don't think you have
to stay stuck in this
$1600 like that you know a $2,000 I mean
a guy called in the other day that was
you know that that was his rent so I
want you to consider your options here
and I think that when you feel backed
into a corner you're backed into a
corner but I want you to really
challenge yourself to open your to open
your mind up to look like what could I
do what could I do to make $3,000 a
month because suddenly if you make
$3,000 a month now you got you know 600
you almost got 7 $1,000 a month and now
we're getting into like a regular income
zone right right average the average
before you say well but average is
around
67,000 okay that's average around 67,000
a year combined that's where most people
are um what is real quick because we're
running out of time this is an income
play yeah uh Rebecca what does your
husband make really quick 3,800 a month
3,800 a month okay if you're making so
roughly annually about I'm going to say
50 and 52 so Rebecca here's the deal I
understand your situation with your kids
but these are the this is the pitfall of
government programs you feel like you
can't make more money because then
they're going to penalize you and you
need these Services these but I'm
telling you you making more money gets
you out of government housing get you
off and you you guys can afford it it's
Ming with your confence got to be making
more money if you just make an 18 hour
do1 18 hours $18 an hour that's going to
put you right just shade under 3,000 a
month that Jade's talking about listen
your ability to move forward on all of
this and getting a car I'm looking at
cars right now $4,000 for a Toyota
Corolla in Portland Maine 142,000 mies
go make money get Transportation go make
money get out of government housing go
make money supplement your kids services
this is about increasing your income
getting out of debt is going to give you
Freedom you guys can do this but you
have to attack it like their life and
your life depends on it this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com and
get up to 35% off that's blinds.com to
learn more rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Jade warshaw the
phone number to jump in is
8825 5225 we want to help you out on
your money questions your work rated
questions let's go to Brent in
Philadelphia Brent how can we help
can you hear me okay I can Brent what's
going on hey yeah uh thank you so much
for taking my call you guys Jaden uh Ken
I uh um Ken just really quick I uh I
actually just ordered your book a few
days ago from paycheck to purpose that's
probably G to help me uh get some ideas
with uh um my career but uh main issue
the main issue or the main question I
have today uh involves our uh second
baby we just found out a couple weeks
ago we're having our second child very
nice
congrats thank you I appreciate it um so
with with that in mind we're trying to
find uh some prenatal care and uh we're
looking at using a
midwife but uh we're trying to figure
out how to cash flow it our I just went
through the numbers through our
insurance company and uh found that uh
it's the Midwife is a lot more
affordable but it's
still um still G to be about $6,500 out
of our pockets uh before insurance will
even cover it we have a pretty high
deductible plan okay um but uh our
finances are pretty tight at the moment
so I'm just kind of looking for a little
advice on maybe ways that we could you
know possibly cash flow it or um maybe
you know step up in the work department
uh what's making finances tight what's
making the finances tight right now well
uh it's I think it's more of like a um I
don't know if it's necessarily an income
issue I currently I bring home about
$4,000 a month so about 48 or 48,000
okay a year um our mortgage currently is
about 1266 a month we currently owee
about 169,000 on our house okay um and
then currently we have a couple of debts
I have some student loans that just went
back into repayment now you guys have
spoken of that often um so I about
39,000 there and then 11,000 in person
well okay so I'm crunching the numbers
on there um currently with all of our
current expenses we've been trying to
cut in different areas but uh we're only
only ending up with maybe a couple
hundred dollars extra a month if that
like two or three like two or three
hundred extra a month two or 300 a month
yep okay yeah um I'm why do you say that
it's not an income thing it definitely
is cuz I thought well Jade's going to
sit down and help you with that budget
but after you walk through all this
you're telling me there's not a lot of
fat and then you're saying it's not an
income thing so I'm
confused okay um it is an income you get
my
point yeah I get it yeah so so I I I I
jumped in there real quick I I I want to
get back to Jade but I mean if I'm if
I'm you I'm looking at $6,500 is a
number that I'm circling on a piece of
paper and I go as a dad as a husband I
got to come up with
$6,500 for this situation and I've got
nine months in counting you got n mons
ticking down so I so I start with what's
that goe you need to find a th000 extra
dollars a month that's what it boils
down to you need to find a th000 extra
dollars a month y get after it my friend
I'd be dividing it by 65 n by 6500 and
and now I know what my Mark is and I got
to get after it and comma and that's the
first thing because that you can go out
and door Dash that right you can U
instacart your way into that Ken I don't
want him instacarting forever no and
you're bringing another person into this
world and they and these people can eat
okay these babies eat and when they turn
three years old it just is Off to the
Races so you're going to need to find a
way longterm to increase Beyond
$4,000 um a month and K Coleman take
well I just want to ask you real quick
until we talk about the future what are
you doing now for the for the the job so
currently I work for a large Automotive
manufacturer I'm one of their field
service reps what does that mean so so I
basically I'm I'm technical support for
dealerships like
computers so um like so if you have a
mechanic you know someone that turns
wrenches on your car at a dealership
whenever they have questions they like
if they have a car that they can't fix I
basically they can reach out to me and I
step in and give them advice on how to
fix it wow so you're you're Consulting
wow wow so you're Consulting
mechanics essentially yes which means
you can fix
cars yes and it feels like that is a
awesome way to be making some extra
money is taking one of your top skills
that's that is at a premium are you
laughing I'm just laughing because I've
actually been tossing around the idea of
maybe you know tinkering and flipping
some equipment on the side my friend I
would stop tossing the around and I'd
grab a hold of it and do it because
because listen I'm not knocking door
Dash or delivering pizzas the ramay show
is never going to knock any work however
time is money have you ever heard that
old phrase M so using your premium
skills meaning the skills that I can get
the most money for my time is the play
for you right now and you fixing stuff
up and flipping it I stink and love that
idea there's real money in that and
again we we've got a Target and I love
what Jade is saying long term we we're
now going okay what do I want to do
because the reason you bought my book is
cu you're thinking about the long term
15 years 20 years down the road what
does that life look like what are you
doing for work that far down the road
yeah that's true yep but what are you
thinking you got an
idea well um I been that that's part of
why I like kind of wanted to start
thinking because there are jobs
available like farther down the line at
least for my career but they're all all
back in uh where the companies based uh
it's one of the big manufactur in
Michigan when I asked you that question
so when I asked you that question you
had an answer and then you begin to
think through it and you're dealing with
some fear and doubt I've coached almost
10,000 people on the Ken Coleman show
who call me up and they act like they
don't know what they want to do and I
always find out about 2 minutes in they
do they're just afraid to say it so
because I'm your friend and Jade your
friend and we don't judge anybody what's
that thing that you've been thinking
about that you want to do just say
it well I let's see see you're already
trying to couch it just say it I'll tell
you if I think you're
crazy I I mean I really want to work
with a um like doing some engineering
type work there we go I
don't but the avenue to do that is to go
back go ahead go go back to what
so uh we have to move back to Michigan
so we right now we live in
Pennsylvania but uh we'd have to move
back to michig which my wife why that's
the only place you can do that type of
engineering
work I I mean I could move to a job
similar to the one I currently have for
another company no my friend that way
Brent you know what kind of engineering
work you want to do
yes you are limit you are limiting
yourself to saying that you can only do
it in the state of Michigan am I
right
I think you're right why why I know you
think I'm right did you say you think
I'm right yeah oh okay I'll tell you why
Jade I think that's because Brent you
have that's where you think you've got
relationships and that's the only place
you can get that kind of engineering
work because you used to live there and
you used to work there I think you limit
yourself because you struggle with a lot
of self-doubt is this true
Brent that's true all right Brent now
how is it that I know that I've never
met you before in my life I'll tell you
how I know it I can hear on you and I'm
not judging you I'm telling you my
friend that we all deal with that I deal
with doubt I listen Jade does we all
deal with it what I'm trying to get you
to see real quick is that you have been
limiting yourself based on your own
beliefs you when I walk you through it
you laugh at yourself and
chuckle because you know I'm just saying
straight up common sense that Michigan
and the previous company and the
previous industry is not the only place
that a guy with your talent and your
passion and your experience and your
desire can do engineering work is that
true or
false that's true all right then so
here's the deal back to the issue at
hand start using that skill set right
now because you got to come up with
$6,500 for that Midwife and that's the
best way for you to do it read the book
from paycheck to purpose it's going to
be like you and my me and your ear with
the speech I just gave you and you my
friend need to start to connect and
begin to look without committing look
around the country look for companies
and industries where the engineering
work that you are qualified to do where
you can do it and as you begin to look
you'll begin to see possibilities that
you never saw before Brent
congratulations on that baby but right
now my friend $6,500 on a whiteboard
Circle it and start getting after it
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Co Jade warshaw joins me hey folks if
you're tuning in right now live uh or
later and you're watching out and you're
going should I hang around a little bit
longer trust me next segment you don't
want to miss it Jade warshaw special
segment how to save money and still
entertain the right way during the
holiday season this is the gift that
keeps on giving this segment so I can't
wait exed and I get to just sample
whatever she's bringing in here so for
me it's just uh you just want snacks kin
you know what I'm a simple man so I'm
very excited about that all right Clara
is up in Louisville Kentucky Clara how
can we
help hey guys I am thrilled to be able
to talk to you guys well we are thrilled
to talk to you what's happening yay I
have a question more for Jade my money
girl um okay I'm gonna I'm gonna smoke a
Sig while you guys talk this will be
great
okay we are looking at buying a house
next year um and we want to know if
we're crazy or if we're rushing into it
or if our numbers are looking okay in
what order we need to do things okay so
tell me more right now we have um
$6,200 um on a credit card okay $7,000
on a truck and then a
$20,000 home equity line of credit okay
um within the past since August we've
paid off $34,000 in credit card debt
good so we're we're on a roll um and my
goal is to have the credit cards and the
truck paid off by March
okay um and then I didn't know do
I not pay on the home well I pay the
minimum payment on the home equity line
of credit and um do our three to six
months emergency savings and then when
we sell our house pay that off and still
have 20% to put down on the new house I
pay it off I'd work to pay it off for
two reasons a it's less than half of the
value of your home I'm guessing
like it's less than
half yeah we owe 124 on our house and we
could sell it for 230 yeah because it's
less than half of that 124 I'd go ahead
and pay it off and here's the thing if
you don't pay it off it's going to cut
into your your winnings right when you
sell the house right so you may as well
pay it off so that money goes right back
into your pocket again it's that idea of
a forced you're forcing yourself to save
the money by paying off this 20,000 does
that make sense okay so you're going to
get it back need we still need the 3 to
6 months MH before we buy or can we take
that out of the um what we make on the
house um again it's what you're saying I
see what you're saying but you need to
get the 3 to six months in place first
and then when you sell the house that
money is going towards the next
house okay so just that whole chunk goes
straight towards the next house because
you're going to need it right well how
much are you trying to put down
um well we would only need about 70,000
to put down uh the house we're looking
at is around 300 and how much sorry you
told me this but I missed it when you
sell the house how much will will it
bring in
total uh
230 no no no how much will you take home
we should have oh um we should have
about 110 110 so you're saying and
that's after Fe is that after fees and
you've considered all that no that's
before okay so let's consider fees and
let's let's knock off
15 all right and let's say that you
let's say you bring home 95 so you're
saying hey we don't we didn't we never
plan to put that full 95
down and we can take some of that and
put it as our emergency
fund right well what what would we still
have the
20% listen the way my mind works I'm
like I want to put the full 95% down or
the full 95,000 down 90 okay how long
will it take you to save up three to six
months um maybe two months I would
listen
listen save up that three to six months
it's all the same you know what I'm
saying it's a big pool of money and I
see what you're trying to do you're kind
of trying to shift it so you can move
faster I I would rather you have that
extra $115,000 to put down on this
mortgage it's okay in the long run
you're going to thank yourself for it
and it's only G it's not like it'd be
one thing if you said Jade it's going to
take us six more months to save up or
another year to save up that'd be maybe
a little different I might change my
answer maybe not but um in this case
it's two months like just wait two
months right you know and then you've
got more money you've got $155,000 more
in your pocket and that's going to go
towards your mortgage I love that
idea okay all right well thank you
you're welcome my problem CL did did you
get what you needed from Jade you needed
me anything from me at all I mean
anything
nothing your cigarettes gone out no I
don't think I do oh great I see how we I
see how this is Clara Merry Christmas I
see how this is oh no we love you Clara
thank you very much Merry Christmas yeah
she didn't want to ask me anything
listen Ken and that sweater I get it I
know I think it's intimidating you know
it puts off a uh puts off the wrong Vibe
I guess it's very it's
very Alex is up in San Antonio Texas
Alex how can we
help uh yes sir uh good afternoon um I
owe my sister $220,000 that I would want
I would like to pay her back um she W me
this money earlier in the year and uh uh
we invested the money uh but it it
didn't pan out so I was uh calling for
your opinion on getting the loan and so
what wish would be the best type of loan
okay hold on a second so you you you got
your sister to give you $20,000 for some
type of business investment what was the
in yeah what was it it was property but
it's out of the country it's in Peru
okay we got a little dicey and it hasn't
panned out what does that mean I would
like to pay her the money well I know
what does that mean it didn't pan
out well we've run into some obstacles
legal obstacles uh evidently the people
they were that we were dealing with
weren't entirely honest with us so the
money's gone and you have no
recourse right what's your how's your
sister taking
it well she's been pretty patient with
me she's she's not harassing me at all
or keep reminding me when were you in
any way when were you supposed to pay
her back like what was tell me the
initial plan cuz I'm I'm trying to gauge
um what your timeline is here we were
supposed to pay within a couple of
months uh it's been almost a year and it
it's gone out it's gone just a little
bit longer than I would wanted to got it
okay well you're but you're broke you're
broke and you're thinking now I got to
get this monkey off my back with my
sister so I'm going to go get a loan and
I'm then going to just pay the bank back
and I just think that's ridiculous I'd
rather you be spending all of your time
and effort just paying your sister back
you don't need to go to a bank or a
credit union or some private loone shark
type situation where they're going to
charge you enormous interest rates just
start paying her back if could you pay
her $1,000 a month what would need to be
true for you to pay her $1,000 a month
or $2,000 a month could that
happen yes I could pair a th000 possibly
2,000 if you really discipline ourselves
then start doing it like this your
sister man she loaned you the money man
up start paying it back what was that
patient enough with me and I I would I
would prefer to just pay her pay her
because you can't pay her 20,000 so pay
her what you can cuz here's what can
happen I want I want lay out two sides
of this unless you tricked
her right when you said hey sis let me
borrow 20,000 I have this real estate
thing that I want to invest in when you
say the word invest you any person knows
okay there's a chance I could make money
and then there's a chance I can lose
money so she I'm guessing she knew going
in there was a chance that you would
lose this money and if that was the case
she wouldn't get her return back as
quick or she wouldn't at least get the
money that she invested back as quickly
so
go ahead so there is part of that there
is part of that that's true you both
agreed on this thing I think it was a
terrible agreement but you both agreed
to it so there is part of that where
it's like okay like you you said you
were investing in this it didn't pan out
so it's going to take a minute to get
the money back I'm afraid of you getting
a loan because I think if you get a loan
it's going to cause you to move slower
on this than you need to because as Ken
said the monkeyy off your back now you
can just be willy-nilly with it when
it's your sister you're GNA you know
move I don't know if I can say you can
move hell in Earth to to get this money
right and so I want that kind of
intensity for you to pay her back
because you don't like this and I like
that you don't like it because that's
what's going to make you move and you
need to move my brother and let me tell
you something if you go get a loan that
interest payment is going to be more
punishment for something that you
already did that was dumb don't multiply
dumb learn from the stupid mistakes
we've all done them move forward start
paying her what you can each month
you'll get get through this this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Jade warshaw and
you know we've for years and years and
years decades we coaching people uh to
win with their money and a big part of
it is budgeting every dollar the world's
greatest budgeting tool saving money and
so this segment is all about you saving
money in the holiday season I turn turn
it over to my my unbelievably qualified
budget Queen herself budget Jade warshaw
has got a a plethora of things here that
I get to sample take it away man okay so
you're right I love it we're doing this
money thing it's that time of year it's
the holidays Ken yes parties is what I'm
talking about Christmas parties New
Year's Eve parties they're all over the
place and you want to participate even
if you're in baby step 2 paying off debt
you want to find a way to participate
and the number one thing I I I would
take a poll if you want the number one
thing when you go to somebody's house
and you're like I got to bring something
it's a bottle of wine right let me bring
a bottle of wine but then your mind
immediately goes to okay like I only
spend like $7 to $10 on a bottle of wine
but I don't want to walk in there you
know with a Barefoot you know the
Barefoot with a Yellow Tail right so do
I need to spend $30 and honestly can
they really tell the difference can you
tell the difference Ken be
it's expensive bot find out it's about
time this is a $30 bottle of wine that
was brought to me in my home all right
I'm not going to so when you pour it I
don't want to look I feel I'm going to
look this way so cuz I I want to be able
to figure out if I can tell yeah cuz if
I see you pour it then I'm cheating so
this is the it's a $30 bottle of wine
that somebody brought me okay compared
to my favorite bottle of wine which is
$9.99 you're kidding me $9.99 really
it's my favorite it's called aoic red
now K oh yeah yeah okay have you poured
it yes okay okay drink the first one I
know I know which is
which taste it always have to do the
sound effect kills the guys in the booth
that's pretty good that's pretty good
okay okay uh I need to uh no no no
you're not wiping it you're washing it
down already I was going to eat
something okay here we go that's a
different
portion now this one is much smoother
without question
which one did I pick you don't know you
picked my favorite I picked a $10 one
you Pi a $10 wine the 10 I'm not kidding
you you picked the $10 wine over the $30
wine I have no idea wow okay so if
you're looking for a good little
disappointed in my
palette red okay I'm going to hold on to
these two over here for the commercial
break put those right over here the
reason it's better is cuz it's a blend
so if you're going to get a cheaper
bottle of red go for the blend don't
don't go like a Cabernet or .99 $9.99
are by way I want to add a little value
to this because you're the budget Queen
I would take Jade's bottle and I would
show up with pride to the party and just
present it and say this is one of my
favorite wines it's a blend say a little
something about it they don't know it's
$10 unless they look it up I love it all
right let way all right now I do think
that there's a little bit more um I'm
not a big white with the white wine kind
of deal so Ken I I just all right I
can't see what you're doing all right
here's the first one all right now what
what am I choosing between these are
Peno greos
okay that's very refreshing I like that
now try the next one by the way one of
these is a $38 bottle of wine I think
it's 38 it's my favorite pulle
f um I like the flavor of the second one
better okay flavor of the second one
better in this case you did pick the $30
wine but is it truly k a $25 difference
or $20 difference I would tell you no so
would you be okay if somebody brought
this this Cupcake wine how much is this
wine guys I have a picture here this
Cupcake wine
is oh boy it's cheap it's $9.99 I think
9.99 yeah there wasn't that big
difference there was not a big
difference now honest admittedly I'm not
a penino guy if you're truly concerned
about this what I suggest just get a
bottle of that well you know
Martinelli's
it's not it's non-alcoholic it's that
apple cranberry sparkling juice am I
trying that next no but the point is
there's no expectation when it's that
it's like okay I know what it is you
drop some cranberries in it it's sparkly
it's still festive and it's like under
$5 so if you're unsure what wine to
bring bring the non-alcoholic kind
Martinelli's it's great the sparkling
apple cranberry then there's there's no
there's no Stigma attached I'm trying to
stay on Focus so we need to go to the
next one this $10 wine is fantastic
fantastic now I feel like my advice is
going to be better in the next hour
listen I didn't have any you're hogging
at
all it's my role I'm supposed to be the
taster if you want to switch rolls then
that's your problem no I'm going to do
mine off camera all right what do we got
next so if you're going if you're
hosting you're like Jade I'm not a wine
thing I'm not doing the beverage what
else should I bring sweet snacks I was
going to go with the cheese and crackers
next Ken oh I apologize cheese and
crackers chees and crackers now here's
the good co-host there you go we lost if
you're going to do it buy a block block
of cheese yourself and Grate it and and
slice it yourself you're going to earn
so much more money back into your pocket
okay if you buy a block you can buy a 16
O block of store brand cheese and it's
43 cents an ounce really but if you buy
it pre-sliced you're paying almost
double per ounce okay it takes two
second it takes 2 minutes to just slice
it up yourself and it tastes better see
if you can tell which one now okay so we
have pre-sliced and then uh Jade sliced
oh so these are just for me to sample
yes all right I'm going to skip the
cracker and go right to a little bit of
the cheese okay you're skipping the
cracker wow yeah you know for time I
want to get right to it you know there
you go not bad okay and then try the
other
one can you tell the
difference IND discernible IND
discernible I can't tell the difference
but you saved money and I always say
like listen it's store brand cheese the
same cheese it's the same one is the
store brand you saved uh $2 by slicing
it yourself and I always say like Buy
store brand don't go crazy on the cheese
if you want to spend money get fancy
crackers okay the crackers are what that
makes the plate look pretty they're what
give it like some have you seen have you
seen the movie Four Christmases yeah who
hasn't you could always go spray cheese
no that's no that's disgusting king
Coleman I know that's not even real
cheese Lobby are laughing though those
people in the lobby thought that was
funny you know horse devour anyone it's
one my favorite hers yes all right now
let's talk about dessert if you really
to me if you bring a dessert if you
really want to look like you did
something but not really do something
bring a dessert now here's the thing if
you go to Kroger you go to Publix you go
to Hive wherever and you get something
out of the bakery do not bring it to the
party in that old you know that plastic
tin that it comes in that's like when
you try to open it up you know what I'm
talking about yes great sound effect I
wasn't ready for that don't bring it put
it on a nice platter oh this is a very
nice platter here but better yet just
make it yourself so we have two brownies
here Ken which I can't tell one is made
by you one is made by me it's a little
bit more rustic it's a little more homey
but it also looks very fudgy and
delicious the other one is a Store br
and by the way I was able to make
brownies at home for $2 cheaper than
buying them and I got more out of it
okay the store bought ones I spent uh
very exciting $14 or something like that
on them all right so we're running short
on time so I just a bite of each tell me
which is best which is best okay you
tell me and get into it K get involved
tell I don't know if this is store or
you but it looks good I got some
powdered something on the top get into
it oh oh
Lord oh that's unbelievable I don't have
enough time James you have to come in
here and help me now try that old crusty
one over there and you tell me which one
I think she gave it
away it's it's light brown I will tell
you the one I just had was very moist
it's fantastic don't give me a light
brown brownie what's wrong with you guys
at
Publix it's not the same it's not even
close whatever you got in there that was
very
fudgy it had moisture in it in the sense
this is dry if you want my brownie
recipe go to Jade warshaw on Instagram
I'll post it this weekend yeah I'll post
it how long does it take you to make
those that's what people want 5 minutes
you make those brownies in 5 minutes
it's all the ingredient yes you put all
the ingredients in One Bowl there's no
steps you put it all in one bowl mix it
up put it in the oven they cook for 45
minutes it's easy okay I'm going to show
you guys how to make them Sam do you
like these I'm going to tell you this
man is a lucky man he's a lucky man it's
amazing he's not 600 lb my 600 lb life
folks I'm not just saying this cuz she's
my friend and cooworker and co-host this
is the best brownie I've ever had jadeen
seriously this recip you're not the
first to say that Ken @ Jade warshaw on
Instagram
ladies get the recipe she's going to
post it tonight I got to go find a glass
of milk we got to pay some bills don't
move this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically in your money in your work
and in your relationships the phone
number is 8825 5225 I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw joins me 8825 5225 is the number
we'd love to coach you up merry
Christmas everybody let's get to it this
hour Chris is joining us in South Dakota
Chris how can we
help how's it going guys uh we're having
a blast man what's going on with you
awesome well um earlier this week my
wife and I paid off the rest of our debt
come on come on all right let's
celebrate how
much uh in
total let's see here it was 40 from my
pickup another 28 for her car and a few
odds and ends along the way so I'd say
70,000 years way to go Chris how's that
feel feels really good
man your your debt-free Christmas that's
going to be a special day isn't it yeah
that's what we told each other we were
going to do for uh our Christmas gifts
to each other this year is we're just
going to pay off pick up and we'll uh
we'll call it a wash oh man that's great
that's awesome congrats what can we do
for you today um so I I don't know the
baby steps as well as I should um
however my my predicament now is that
we're debt free the house is paid off as
well want to start farming that's always
been
always been my goal but it's very
expensive to start
farming so do I invest my money into my
retirement or do I just start saving up
little by little and put down on some
Acres you can do both biggest question
you can do both um congrats number one
on having no home payment you left out
that little nugget of wonderful
information um so yeah assuming let's
let me kind of pull us back a little bit
so the you have no Consumer Debt you
know you have no home debt um do you
have any other money saved besides
retirement like emergency we've got the
85,000 in the bank 85,000 in the bank so
that's that's I'm assuming well beyond 3
to six months of expenses um how much do
you earn every
year myself is about 100,000 in my wife
is about another 40 to 45 okay so you
guys are $145,000 a year you got $85,000
in the bank so let's really look at this
is there a way um if you had to say
three 3 months of of expenses basic
expenses what is that for
you oh boy it's now the pickups are paid
off it's minimal exactly um so cell
phone payments are 200
um I'd say probably 500 a month if that
for everything including all of our
utilities oh wow that doesn't include
groceries though yeah you need to think
about your yeah no that doesn't include
groceries sold a family of three I don't
know 300 bucks a month okay let let's
say's round up to two grand a month yeah
let's say2 or $3,000 a month all right
and so that's N9 or 10,000 just for a
good measure let's say you got let's see
you let's say you keep
$20,000 as three to six months of
expenses all right and then you can turn
around and take that other 65,000 and
now we get to decide okay we got
$65,000 uh are we going to put this
towards land or real estate or what ever
it is that you've said you want to do so
we're going to earmark that over there
you and your wife can decide what
happens with that money the next thing I
want to make sure you have in place is
with your incomes are you guys investing
15% of your income every
month so not yet uh I I took a new job
here recently and I'm not allowed to
have a not allowed as a wrong term they
don't offer a 401k until I've been here
for about a year okay so I still have
eight months roughly until I can start
investing in that I've had a 401 before
my previous uh jobs okay my wife does
like a 403b okay great so I mean she's
she's putting in um she takes care of
insurance and I mean after taxes it's
not much of a paycheck that she brings
home well between the so they're
automatically pulling some into her 43b
between the two of you and this might
mean that you need to go and open some
Roth IRAs between the two of you I want
you investing 15% of your combined
income each month so that's when you
walk away from here that's the answer to
the one question of hey do we need to
start putting towards retirement the
answer is yes and the answer is that 15%
um of you guys' income each month so
whether it's going into her 403b I'd
rather you guys start with the Roth IRAs
and do those first and then if you're
able to Max those out and there's still
money left then you know move it on to
her 403b and then by then if you still
have money left over you know you've got
your 401k that's opening up so that's
kind of the order of business that I
would do that and then again you've got
the 65 ,000 there that you can say okay
with any extra income and money that we
have we can add to that and we can start
piling up cash in order to make your
next Real Estate or land purchased is
that is that
fun it it does however the way the way
I've been thinking about it is buying
land at let's say 7 to $10,000 an acre
year that that's my next career goal I
want to I want to be a farmer but how to
pencil it out with the interest rates
right now at the bank trying to buy
loans and try to get land it just
doesn't pencil out wondering if instead
of doing the 15% for my retirement I
mean land would be a retirement option
as well if I ever had to sell it or if I
rent it out that would bring a good
living as well it would 15% for that it
is but you want that portfolio to be
balanced you don't want it all in real
estate just like do you see what I'm
saying you do want to have a nest egg
that you know you can get two cash we're
not waiting for a buyer we're not
waiting for like you're drawing money
off of that monthly and so that is
really important for you to have
because there is going to be a time
where you're not working and you want
this money coming and you don't want to
just depend on Social Security that's
right so it is important to have a nest
egg in investment accounts and Chris
listen you know this far better than I
but I read enough about America's
farmers and the business itself it's a
very tough business and has a tremendous
amount of risk involved and so you don't
want to take the 15% which is baby step
four and say well I'm going to put it
into the land that's that's highly
specul relative business you would agree
with that
statement I would yeah so let's let's
real quick we only got about a minute
and a half I just want to get some quick
numbers what kind of Acres would you
like if you had the money now what what
what what size how many acres are you
looking for I'd love to have a th Acres
yeah so it I know that's going to take a
lifetime of working to get up to that
yeah but but what kind of farming do you
want to
do uh just corn and soybeans so all
right so what's the minimal amount of
acreage that you need to be able to uh
test this
idea uh so testing I was just going to
try to buy 40 acres just to start and
I'd have my full-time job and then you
know gradually after I've got the 40
acres paid off I want to buy that
upfront so I don't have to you know go
to a
bank I like this IDE to keep buying more
all right so now we've got a number in
our mind right at 7,000 an acre that's
$280,000 right yep okay I you know what
I challenge the 40 acres i' I'd go you
know listen we talk about people testing
side hustles all the time on social
media but listen M you can still test
something with dirt and seeds so I I
guess Jade's giving you great financial
advice hopefully you do exactly what we
tell you to do and invest for yourself
because I don't want you to sacrifice
your long-term
Investments uh in a speculative farming
business however could you save 150 200
Grand buy a smaller plot
let's grow it let's test it we PID cash
no risk we got the land that we could
resell I think this is doable I guess
that's the point I wanted to give you a
hug and an encouragement to say I think
you could get in this game for a lot
less money than you think and see if it
is the long-term play I would challenge
you to think about that in the days
ahead but we're proud of you great job
getting debt free this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw joins me Merry
Christmas America thrilled that you were
with us we're here to help you win in
your life your money your work in Rel in
your relationships
88255 225 is the phone number let's go
to Megan who joins us now in
Jacksonville Megan how can we
help hi um I'm a brand new follower and
over just this pack past week has
listened to The Total Money Makeover
audio book twice wow um my husband and I
have just begun applying these
principles to get out of debt and change
our financial future cool and after
reducing our emergency fund and
liquidating our assets we'll have about
14,000 to dump into debt paying off
multiple
creditors um so soon it'll be just one
creditor um aside from the mortgage um
so we'll only have one piece of debt and
I would just like advice regarding this
particular piece of debt uh if it makes
sense for our family to pay it off and
keep it for the long haul or sell it
what's the piece of dead is it a
car yes it's a van it's a 2020 Ford
Transit 15 passenger van
wow why such a big
van uh well we are a family of eight so
we have um my husband and I we have six
Sons ages two down up to uh 11 bless
your heart you are you need some rest
yes so tell us the the details on the
van how much do you owe on
yeah so I mean we bought it in March uh
which is it was crazy the market was
insane painful time to buy but we were
kind of maxed out in our the our prior
8seater van and it was just on its last
leg so you spend on it
but um well that one has it was paid off
that one was paid off but the one that
we have now so the one that's in
question we our balance right now is
47,000
663 okay 47,6 63 okay and what's it
worth if you were to sell it private
sale um so I Kelly Blue booked it and it
value is about
56,600
56,600 okay so the question then is are
you able to get your hands because what
you could do if you wanted to you've
still got the 14,000 you could get the
difference cleared up and you could sell
this thing it's a $10,000 difference
sell this thing and then put whatever I
mean what what would the next step be do
you guys have anything do you have other
vehicles for the family is my
question we this is our only vehicle the
only vehicle
period yes okay so what would it cost to
get you said before you had an eight
passenger van which is great what would
it cost to get another used eight
passenger
van um well it varies I
mean um there's a lot more options it's
obviously a lot a lot cheaper um if the
advice was to sell it then that one
thing that I would be asking what should
I be looking for I mean should I be
looking for something you know trying to
go as cheap as we can that you know will
be more shortterm or well you know just
trying to here's my answer to that I
think that I do want you out of this
vehicle I think it's more than need and
it's too expensive for you um in order
to say what you what you need and what
you can get can you tell me what your
income
is um my husband we make well our annual
income is 120,000 okay 120 so our
general rule of thumb is we don't want
any more than half of your annual income
in vehicles okay so between the two of
you you could really consider this two
ways that's $60,000 split between the
two of you if this is your only vehicle
and you plan on being a one vehicle
family there is a world that you could
pay this off and just keep this as your
vehicle if you think you can pay it off
in 2 years or less that's your bag if
you want to do that if you're like Jade
I want to get out of debt I don't want
this thing we bought too much car then
there's a world where you say okay as as
we're working to pay off debt we know
that we're going to have to fill the gap
on this because there's a $10,000 upside
down and you're then going to need some
money somewhere to buy an eight
passenger van that's used
M right so you've got some options here
and you've got to decide ultimately can
you can you kick it and pay this thing
off super fast or do we need to really
consider some Ken you're looking at
Vehicles what do you see yeah here's a
question for you um can you fit eight
people can you do the six boys in a
traditional third row
minivan um we could yes I mean that is
what we had before um the question was
and kind of the reason that we also
wanted to go up because we weren't sure
whether or not we
would expand our family anymore in the
future and it was just kind of Well we'd
rather have you know at least have the
space for it and not have to then at
that point like okay well this and I
understand but now but now you're in
agreement with Jade and I that me we
probably shouldn't have bought a van for
the future we should buy a van for the
now
yes um that the other benefit like I
said um we had we moved out of the city
um we're a little more rural now and
having that extra space for when we do
go into town and being able to get
groceries and all question so I don't
want to try to talk you out of it so
I'll answer Jade's question I've got
right here a
2015 Ford Transit passenger 150 XL
medium roof with a sliding room
passenger side door I feel like I Ed car
sale from James uh but now this is in
Murphysboro all right so this is
Tennessee but it's
$26,900 it's got 78,000 Mi but it's 26
that's that's a lot less than than uh
than the the what 65 no uh 47 is what
you owe on the current one so you guys
can definitely find a a van that large
for half she can but she's also got to
clear the $110,000 difference no I know
and I'm letting you help her on that but
we can at least get out of that car
payment well I'm glad you found that
because now that I'm looking at that I'm
like all right that's there she'd have
to save up the 26,000 there plus the
10,000 to get to get right so she's
already at 30 37,000 that's 10,000 less
than where she's at I can do it one
better I mean I was looking at minivans
in the 15s and 16s here's one in
Jacksonville 2019 Dodge Grand Caravan
35,000 miles 198 that's not bad so for
the now that's not bad here's where I'm
at and there there's not a bad decision
here um because your debt right now is
minimum you've got the 14,000 you'll
knock it out and the only debt left is
this right so if I'm in your shoes other
than our mortgage but that's another if
I were in your shoes um laid we've laid
out all the information and now I'm
going to tell you what Jade warshaw
would do if I were in your shoes I would
keep this vehicle and pay it off this
year in one year because it's your only
vehicle it's less than it's less than
half of your take-home pay like for the
year right and it's your only one I like
that I I'm going to keep this car it's
good it's serving a purpose it's going
to get you towards the future you like
it and the other options aren't enough
of a payoff for in my opinion to go
Grand it's four grand a month to knock
it out in a year yeah knock it out in a
year four grand a month do you like that
yeah and yeah I mean not yet uh I was
and it's something that you know there
there was that security I mean it was
expensive but I mean we got it with only
13,000 miles on it listen you're not
going to make me feel good about the
fact that you went out and got a car
note
now yeah you but you're in it now
learning you're in exactly you're in it
now pay it off and make me the promise
that next time you guys when it's time
to upgrade when it's time to get another
car stack up that cash because I don't
want you guys in car I don't want you in
car debt ever again the car the car note
is the difference between the middle
class and the wealthy class all right
that's the money right there that people
you know it's you need that money you
need to invest it that's where your kids
college is it's all wrapped up in that
carot so just you and your husband say
all right we got we got one out of it
but we're not borrowing money again on
cars I'm proud of you guys yeah
absolutely you guys are going to win we
just knock it out that's right yeah look
get get get gazelle intense on knocking
out that car payment and when you guys
have singular focus on that you'll be
surprised all the good stuff that'll
start to happen when you think okay
let's save a block here let's put it
towards the the car next you know you
guys have a paid off van and you know
all right I put some more money in the
bank before I have another kit I just
wanted to throw that in there listen Ken
you were a used car salesman over there
well Ken's car lot I I like look I like
because people need to know their
options listen you doing that helped us
make the right choice for her there you
go Hey listen money advice Ed car advice
whatever you need we're here for you
this is the ram
sh
[Music]
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey Show I'm kid colan Jade
warshaw joins me this hour and it's such
a privilege to be a part of this show
that helps so many people uh and and I
want to just kind of give you a snapshot
of where we are as we wrap up 2023 we
have done 242 live shows we've talked to
3200 plus callers and we've done 184
debt free screams and get this ready for
this I wish we had a ticker board for
this totally thank you for the drum roll
Jade 36 milon
59,4 and don't forget the
47 and so what an unbelievable year and
so we keep going on that total Jade
because in the lobby of Ramsey solution
standing on the debt free stage are
Donald and Leticia welcome hello how's
it going and I assume you're here to do
your debt free scream is that correct
that's correct oh boy let's go let's
hear the story all right how much debt
did you guys pay off uh we paid off
$152,000
$152,000 how long did that take that
took us approximately 30 months 30
months and what was your range of income
during that time the range of income we
started off at about 120 and we ended
off at about 165 oh nice what do you
guys do for a living uh I actually have
my own uh lawn can land landscaping
company and uh my wife uh she works at
the local hospital um in re Revenue
Integrity excuse me and uh but really
she does everything you know she move
like as a photographer she do t-shirts
she actually is an author she does it
all like that latia so was that the uh
is she responsible for the $45,000 bump
or was this a a partnership in raising
our income uh yes she actually have um a
chair rental a thrown chair rental
business um that she started a couple of
years back and that's what actually gave
us the bone say a throne chair rental
business yes so if I want a queen's
chair I can rent it from you absolutely
come on somebody is that for like oh
don't get her too excited about this
that's going to show up in the office
one day uh is this for like parties and
like weddings baby showers birthday
parties um a lot of pastors use it for
their pastors iversary okay so it's used
for a lot of things photo shoots listen
America don't tell me you can't make
money this woman is renting a throne
okay I know that is the American dream
right there I love that and uh you guys
are from the New Orleans area is that
right oh yeah actually from Pula we like
45 minutes north of New Orleans okay
gotcha all right well fantastic okay so
what happened 30 months ago when you
guys say all right we're going to go on
this debt-free journey and by the way
that's a lot of debt in 30 months I know
it is well to be honest I have heard
about Dave um a couple of years back and
uh we was already kind of like on a
journey without following the Dave
Ramsey plan so we would actually get in
we'll pay off debt and then we'll get
right back in it and we'll just be in
this FR uh Friz uh cycle so what
happened was uh Co hit yeah so for Co
that was uh a blessing and a curse for
us so what happened was um I commute
back and forth to New Orleans every day
and I heard Dave on YouTube and uh I was
the essential worker of course and he
was just telling me how crazy I was and
how stupid I was you know so um I had to
get myself together so I go home and I
go to my wife and I say Hey listen I
have this plan I heard this guy on
YouTube she still shaking her
head and I had to get her to buy in and
I was so sold in Jade kin and uh she
looked at me she says I'm not with it
uhoh uhoh Leticia that was tell us more
tell us how did you get into it so I um
you know he'll be like hey let's watch
Dave Rams I'm like you watch it tell me
what he said right like I don't want to
watch that and they like wait a minute
you want me to watch what now right I
was like you get the information and you
give me a short script of it and so what
he did was he began to like uh because
it was Co and it wasn't like we could do
anything he worked a lot people still
needed their grass Cuts so he worked a
whole lot so he was able to save about
10 grand wow and he came home I think it
was like three or four months he saved
10 grand and so he was like Hey pay
these credit cards off and I'm like with
what and he was like oh I saved the
money because I was listening to you
know Dave
Ram like oh okay so you know I'm like we
have like this healthy uh competition
going on and he always say you know I
like to spin and so I was like I'mma
show him and so you know I had my
businesses going and I was running
specials uh like with my book specials
and Throne chair rental specials was
running it and so I came home and I said
hey guess what paid this credit card off
and so we we had a sheet on the wall and
we would every you know we constantly
coming home and saying I pay that one
and we scratching it off so it became a
healthy competition I love that and I
stopped getting my hair and nails done I
was wearing press on I learned how to do
my own hair from YouTube
not yes so it's a sacrifice that's a
deep deep sacrifice this I'm learning
things right now okay I got to say this
Donald you're a
genius thank you I you need to write a
book for husbands that's what I've been
trying to tell you I I actually think
you're a genius I'm learn I'm like I
can't I try to force stuff you just were
like all right I'm I'm just going to
save up some money and surprise her
you're a genius my man you should write
a book yes sir all right fans fun fun
stuff what was the debt comprised of
curious the uh 152 okay so we had a van
that we financed that was 12,000 my wife
actually had a nce on pet founder that
was 14,000 uhhuh we had 28,000 in credit
cards wow um my wife had 38,000 in
student loans oh wow and we actually
paid off um a home that was
60,000 so we have a paid off home in
this we have a paid off home in this
whoa is it your primary home no you can
tell story okay so what happened was in
the midst of uh before the uh pandemic
happened we were like I say already on a
journey to pay off debt so we acquired a
mobile home that we say hey we'll make
this rental property and then the midst
of renovating I was like why don't we
just live here and rent out our house
and there more money we can save
interesting and so we we lived in the
mobile home and renovated it and um so
you know that's what we did we were on
our journey they paid rent we made money
and we end up selling the home you know
because the market is right so we sold
uh was end up selling the home and made
$28,000 in profit off of that home okay
so now you're still on the Airstream or
whatever it is you're still on the
mobile yes and you own clear clear wow
y'all don't have a payment in the world
and the greatest blessing of it all as
well is because of we live in Louisiana
where it's a hurricane State they have a
program called restore Louisiana and so
because we're in a mobile home and we
did acquire some damages restore
actually um gave us a grant to get a
brand new mobile home so we just was
blessed with a brand new 2023 mobile
home congratulations guys so we are
really doing great are Flo yeah and and
I got to point out your nails look
fabulous thank you yeah absolutely
fantastic I get these all right so uh we
we've only got a couple minutes real
quick tell people what you believe the
key is to getting out of debt um it's
discipline it's knowing that you are
worth it that you are worth being debt
free and not having to struggle and
stress about bills the relief it is to
be able to travel and take a trip
without using a credit card it's such a
overwhelming feeling like it's just like
wow I never believe that we could really
be debt free because you always hear
people say you're going to always have
debt but to be able to go through the
steps the sacrifice being talked about
laugh at like y'all really left y'all
house to live in a mobile home it's so
rewarding because guess what we could do
whatever we want now we're able to give
substantially we're able to be a
blessing and God is constantly pouring
out his blessings to us because we
decided to sacrifice a little so that we
can live like no one else tell she's
preaching I'm ready I'm ready to uh to
call I know man and take an offering I
mean I'm going to do it all
Leticia that's the final word because
that is so powerful you guys are on your
way to being baby steps millionaires so
we want to bless you with a copy of that
book uh Dave's latest book baby steps
millionaires because that's the next
chapter in your amazing story from
mobile home to millionaires that's your
slogan I dig that and then we're also
going to give you a copy of D book totem
Money Makeover to gift to somebody else
cuz you guys have modeled the way and we
know you're going to continue to bless
people by modeling the way so thank you
guys okay you got your son with you so
let's get him up there real quick this
is kelan how old is he 17 17 all right
here we go we've got Donald Leticia
kelan they paid off 152,000 in 30 months
making 120,000 to 165,000 take it away
let's hear your debt free scream y ready
on three 3 2 1 we're dead free yes they
are fantastic I love that story I mean I
got goosebumps I listen I'm ready to
shout that's all I'm saying all right
let's go do it let's go high five and
Shout with that fabulous family hey they
did it you can do it as well we'll be
right back this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by Jade
warshaw the number for you to jump in on
the conversation is
8825 5225 our scripture the day comes
from Luke 2: 7 8 and 9 and she gave
birth to her firstborn son and she
wrapped him in clothes and laid him in a
Manger because there was no room for
them in the end and there were shepherds
out in the field keeping watch by night
and an angel of the Lord appeared to
them and the glory of the Lord Shone
around them our quote today from Calvin
kulage a former president he said
Christmas is not a time nor a season but
a state of mind to cherish peace and
goodwill to be plenteous in mer Mercy is
to have the real Spirit of Christmas
President Calvin kulage a great
contribution cool Cal is what they
called him I believe I think you would
know thank you thank you very much
Colorado Springs Colorado is where we go
Alex is up Alex how can we help hello
how are you I'm s I'm doing great
actually um so I have some good news uh
personally I made I recently made a
pretty big life change um I moved all
the way across the country for a new job
and the um um well the income here is
significantly better it's about twice as
what I was making recently and I'm about
to have a bunch of disposable income
that I've never had um before in my life
and I want to begin um Building Wealth
and planning out my future uh the only
issue is I I still have some debt and
but I also want to do some investing so
I was just wondering how would you
recommend going about that winning
listen I'm excited for you you got
double the income you've got options now
so how much debt do you have laying
around so um I have 9500 in student
loans
okay and that's it oh that's it okay
great um all right and what's your
income what's this doubled salary look
like um so I actually do two jobs I do a
um a teaching job on the side my main
job does 97,000 and then with my
teaching job I make between about five
and 10,000 okay cool and what does that
look like monthly like what are you
bringing home each
month uh about $88,500
okay that's pre-tax after tax is going
to be around 6,000 oh around 6,000 you
said mhm okay
so what would it look like can you get
this debt this 9500 can you have that
gone in four
months I could okay
great so that's thing one do you have
any money or savings laying around let
me ask that first I do actually um in my
bank account I have about 8,000 oh okay
well then we're gonna knock this out
even sooner wow okay so what I'm going
to walk you through um is our series of
baby steps just in case I don't know how
familiar are you are familiar you are
with them but what we say is first step
you're just keeping $1,000 keep it aside
right quick because we need a cushion we
need a barrier between us and life if an
emergency happens so out of that 8,000
today I'd earmark a th000 aside and then
I'd take that 7,000 that's left and I
would put it towards the student loan
and if you can scr together I know it's
the end of the month so this might be in
January if you can scrunch together that
other 2,000 knock it out and it's
gone okay and then um go ahead you go
ahead so another thing I was wondering
though is that um I was hoping to invest
in an IRA I was hoping to begin that
401k going I have about 15,000 but the
IRA I know that there are annual
contribution limits and I was wondering
is it too late this year to hit that no
it's not opening up so I'm gonna get to
that but I want to make sure you
understand it within our framework okay
because there's there's method to
Madness if you every everybody wants to
build wealth and everybody wants to do
that but if you don't do it in the right
way you end up taking steps backwards
and we hate to see that so it's super
duper important that you walk through it
with some method okay because if you
don't have 3 to six months saved what
happens is that money that you saved in
a 401k or an IRA that becomes your
emergency fund and then when it rains
you have to pull from it prematurely and
you get with hit with penalties and fees
and messes up your rhythm of investing
and I really don't want that for you
fair enough
okay yes okay so you've paid off the
student loan in January by February I
want your main focus to not be investing
I want your main focus to be stacking up
3 to six months of savings and I want
that money liquid I don't want you
investing that money okay because if you
were to lose your job if something were
to happen you fall on hard times you
need that money there because I don't
want you going into debt to cover an
emergency okay so February starts your
piling up 3 to 6 months of expenses
basic expenses okay this is not like
your full-blown budget and for anybody
listening 3 to 6 months of expenses that
is not your that is not every item in
your budget okay this is what it takes
to keep your household running when we
say basic expenses so you're doing that
and then then and only then are we
talking about investing now typically uh
Alex we would tell people to pause 401K
investing but you're I'm not going to
tell you that cuz you're literally going
to pay this off in one month it's it's
not even worth the trouble but once you
once you stack up that 3 to 6 months
you're investing all right 15% of your
income if your 401k has a match you can
start with that and then after you hit
the match you can go over to a Roth IRA
you can Max one of those out and if you
still have money left of the 15% you can
go back to the 401K and keep going until
you hit
it okay did I did did I answer your
question or you have more that makes
sense um yeah but uh I was just
wondering is it possible still to invest
um in the for1 in sorry in the ira this
year um I haven't actually opened up an
account but I'm just worried that we're
kind of running into the deadline no
with IAS you have until tax filing so
you can invest all the way up until
April I see okay at least last I checked
did that change Ken Coleman last I
checked you asked the wrong guy I I
don't check those details much yeah it's
not the same as with your 401k you've
got time until I believe that's true
because it's based on the 2023 so I
think that's correct but so yeah keep
going
uh I'm right about that I just wanted to
double check it and Ken is right about
that too um but yeah I love this I love
it I'm excited for you're on your way
young man congratulations listen follow
what Jade told you to do if you do that
you're going to be really wealthy and
just be patient just walk the steps Out
start that investing plan now how old
are you uh 24 oh my oh come now that's
exciting listen and and again I'm going
to say this again I don't know if you're
going to do it or not but if you really
want to do this quickly pause investing
now yeah so just pause it it's a
temporary just quick pause so you can
get that money back in your hands so you
can quickly get the student loan out so
you can quickly save up that 3 to 6
months and then you can hit it hard 15%
oh my goodness you'll it's going to make
your mind blown how quickly you recoup
uh whatever little bit you lost off that
small pause that's exactly right it's
all about momentum Alex and everybody
else I mean that's the the magic of the
baby steps is it allows you to get
emotional M uh momentum which then leads
to financial momentum and then that's
what's really great uh okay so uh
unbelievable here uh I I wanted to bring
back perspective um jade for you as we
wrap up the show today 36 million plus
of our listeners and viewers paying off
debt it is doable um and and I and I've
got to do this cuz she's my friend but
this is really good you see that look I
got a Tilt at the right look at that
money's not a math problem this is her
new book comes out when it's technically
out now oh it is it's on the street okay
I know it been preal so you can get it
now uh Amazon wherever books are sold
yes if you buy it on ramsy solutions.com
it'll ship immediately immediately if
you go on Amazon Barnes & Noble Target
th those sorts of things it will not
ship till January 2nd so keep that in
mind yeah so here's what's great about
it barely over 40 pages includes her
Amazing Story this is a woman who's
walked the walk she's talked the talk
the real reason you're broke and what to
do about it money's not a math problem
and it's about behavior and that's what
I love about this title and Jade has
lived it she and Sam paid almost half a
million dollars off in debt and as we we
WRA Today's Show I just was thinking the
perspective here of all the calls we
have had today plus I could say this
about every show it really is a about
the title of your book it is I'm going
to give you the final word on that it is
about Behavior yes it is money is not a
math problem at the end of the day
you're not going to accomplish anything
if you don't truly believe you can and I
always say if behavior is the car belief
is in the driver's seat belief is what
drives our Behavior whether you believe
you can or you can't you're right and if
you're not getting where you want to go
it's because you don't believe you can
get where you want to go and I say it
all the time you can tell me you won't
do it but don't tell me you can't you
can do it but your belief's got to be in
the right place and this book is all
about that go get it right now Ramy
solutions.com it's in the store be a
great gift cuz it's very affordable it's
the gift that keeps on giving a famous
line from Christmas Vacation how about
that hey big thanks to my colleague my
dear friend Jade warshaw soon to be best
styling author to our fearless leader
old Captain our Captain James Charles
and the amazing crew this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
n